Thank you so much for, uh, for
joining us, Luke, um, uh, you know,
as her getting introduced
where we'll definitely talk
a bunch about, uh, Lee Hood,
uh, based on the work that you
guys, uh, if it's you, you,
you, uh, put together. But,
uh, I really wanted to
start by talking about, uh,
by talking about you and I was just
asking you a moment ago, uh, you know,
how often it is. I, I've seen
any number of times you've, uh,
you've moderated an interview or
moderated a group of panelists,
but how often are you on, on this
end of the, uh, the interview?
Well, increasingly I am on
the receiving end of these
speaking on public radio from
time to time, um, at panels.
Sometimes people want to know at
industry events, you know, what's,
what's hot and interesting for the
journalists. So, no, no. Perfect.
12. Great. I have a whole bunch of
awkward questions here for you. Uh,
so we'll just get started with a couple,
a couple good ones. Um, maybe, maybe just,
uh, just so folks know a
little bit more about you,
can you tell us a little bit about your
background? Uh, you know, kind of how you,
how you made the path from a, I think you
grew up in Wisconsin, if I remember, uh,
all the way to being a,
a biotech journalist and doing
amazing work you're doing now.
Yeah, sure. So I studied journalism
at the University of Wisconsin.
Wasn't sure what a I would specialize
in or even if I would specialize,
that wasn't really a thing in the
90s. It was coming up. Um, but, um,
I ended up getting a job at the Seattle
Times as a general business reporter.
And, uh, uh,
about a year into that stint I
had shown some ability to explain,
uh,
jargony,
boring kind of subjects to
the editors in plain English.
I could bring those things to life.
And at the time the newspaper
still had a biotechnology beat.
Uh, they had a dedicated report on
the business staff and, uh, I, uh,
there were two openings.
It's interesting.
At the time I was about
ready to get promoted and one
was for biotech and Morton
was for retail. So I could have
cup of Starbucks, Costco, Amazon,
and my whole path would've been different.
But I looked at biotech and I thought,
uh, there's science, there's human health,
there's business,
there are ethical issues,
there are all of these
interesting characters, like
charismatic entrepreneurs.
It all changes really fast.
There's no one dominant company.
So in Seattle at the time of the business
desk, uh, you wanted to get ahead,
you would come, or Boeing or Microsoft
and one of the big companies,
but I kind of looked at some of the
stories that were coming out of there and
thought, Oh gee, another jet order
for Singapore or you know, the,
the latest version of windows.
I thought biotech had rich
ingredients for storytelling. And uh,
so I kind of dived in. That
would have been 2001. Uh,
it was just in the wake of the
human genome project. And I had,
this is getting interesting.
I could,
I could imagine doing this a
long time and not getting bored.
We'll come back to Seattle
in a, in a, in a moment. Uh,
cause I'd love to hear kind
of what you've seen, uh, in,
in the Seattle and northwest
geography kind of a cause.
There's obviously been a lot
of change there, but, um, uh,
but you then ended up at economy and
then more recently you've started the
Timmerman report. Ah, you had done
the book, you've done, uh, the Po,
there's a podcast that you
started, uh, you had a brief,
a bit where you're doing
some stuff with stat news a,
so just can you give us a sense of
how you ended up at economy and then,
and then really kind of, you know,
your own entrepreneurial journey, uh,
from going from a larger publication
to going off and doing your own thing.
How did you decide to do that?
Yeah. Well, um, this being Google, I mean,
you understand the disruption that's
occurred in the media business.
Um, and so I was coming
up at a traditional media
company, the Seattle Times,
and uh, realized that, uh, there
wasn't much of a web strategy.
And about the mid two thousands,
they're still very much
wedded to traditional print
advertising and there were
all kinds of painful cuts
and things going on. Um,
and so I thought, you know, I, I
don't think this is for me a longterm,
um, I was beginning to really sink
my teeth into biotech and specialize.
I had done a fellowship at MIT for
science journalists for about a year,
and that was sort of
the moment where it was,
it dawned on me that I could do this,
I might need to figure out the
right structure, um, online, um,
to do that. And it's economy was
that I joined a startup 2008. Um,
and, uh, it was really focused
on all things innovative.
So the two guys and a dog startup all
the way up through the more interesting
projects that say a big company
might be working on and Alzheimer's.
And it was a great window
into the world of biotech. Um,
I didn't have to worry about,
you know,
the daily stock fluctuations so much I
could focus on the science and how it was
being applied. And, uh, so
I developed a following,
um, social media came on board. Um,
it became clear that I had sort of what
you might call high affinity audience.
I wasn't going to reach the largest
number of people in the world with writing
about genomics or you know,
cancer immunotherapy.
But there was a small core of people
who were very intently interested in my
subject material so that,
um, by the time I was, uh,
about to move on from economy 2014,
I was thinking that yes,
I could potentially hang up my own shingle
as an independent media entrepreneur
focused on my biotech niche and then I
can layer in some of these other things
like podcasts. Um, eventually when
I finally got my book published,
I could get that kind of in the portfolio,
um,
as different ways to reach people in the,
the information comments screen.
So you started with the website and then,
uh,
in the background we're building the book,
writing the book.
Is that how it worked or how
did you actually start that?
I started the hood project
while I was still at economy,
but I like a lot of authors.
I got to this point where I realized
I've done all these interviews,
I've got all these documents,
it's a mountain of material.
I've got all my daily deadlines, when
am I actually going to write this thing?
So I actually had to swallow hard and say,
you know what,
I think I need to leave my job if I'm
actually going to write this book.
Basically give myself a leave of absence.
Um,
which was almost a year to actually
write the book, finish it, get it edited.
And then, um, I started
the Timmerman report.
Who was actually the book
that prompted you to, to take
the next step. Yeah. Great.
Okay. That's, that's real interesting.
Different than what I had thought. Um,
so let's, let's, uh, let's
turn our attention to the
book. Um, so, you know, as,
as, as I read through it, one thing that
was striking and I as, as you know, I,
I actually listened to it on audio books.
I'm going to ask you some
questions on that as well. But, um,
but how did you come to the idea
of writing a book to begin with?
Is that just the dream of every journal
is because I can't say that many of the
folks that we interact with have
actually written such a, um, you know,
it's such a long form sort of a, you
know, piece of writing and, you know,
how did you come to choose Lee and how did
the initial interaction, uh, with Lego,
cause I can imagine it being
easy or challenging cause
he's such a unique finger
in this. How did, how did, how
did it start? Yeah, so, um, I,
I was starting to get the
itch to write a book, uh,
in the last couple of years at economy.
Um,
I had some experience writing
magazine type profiles of people.
I thought I enjoyed getting to know
people and their life story as a way of
shining light on the history of
how technologies develop really.
And um,
along in 2011 comes the Steve
Jobs book by Walter Isaacson.
And I read this and I thought,
now this is a great example of what
you might call a living biography, uh,
because he was able to do a whole series
of interviews with jobs for last couple
of years when he was still alive.
And so you could get a lot of rich
detail that you can never get just from
reading the documentary record. You
supplement the record with the interviews.
And so, um, this is, you
know, a big bestseller to it.
So it was kind of inspiring and I
looked around and thought, okay,
I'm in biotech who do I know who has had
some kind of catalytic effect on this
industry and maybe not as many aspects
of tech that jobs did, but, um,
immediately thought of hood.
Now is you remember I was,
I got started at the Seattle Times,
uh, and based there and hood,
um, had, um,
I got to know him very early
on as a newspaper reporter.
So I had a reporter source
relationship with him. Uh,
I had covered his institute
for systems biology,
which was sort of his next big idea
in the wake of the genome project.
Um, and in various startup
companies he had been involved in.
And I knew that there was this tremendous
force of personality and that he was,
he had a signature achievement that I
could explain to anybody on the street.
And that was that he led the team
that developed the first automated DNA
sequencer. So this was a tool
that revolutionized biology,
we can say with the benefit
of hindsight. And it was, uh,
akin to the development of
the, the better, faster,
cheaper semiconductors
that Intel developed, uh,
more Gordon Moore and Bob Noyce had that
kind of a catalytic and enabling effect
on technology.
So I thought hood was a great subject.
When you, uh, so you'd
known him, uh, from, um,
from your time on the
reporting side of it. Uh,
how did you broach that subject with him?
Yeah, that's a good
question. Uh, because, uh,
so looking at those of you who've read
the Isaacson book know that it pulls no
punches. There's the good Steven, but not
so good Steve in there. And uh, you know,
as an independent journalist,
that's the kind of book I would write a,
that's what I'll spend my time on.
So I propose something like this to Lee
and there's going to be a good lead in a
badly in this book.
I told him that I would talk to your
friends and your enemies, your family. Um,
I want to tell the good,
the bad and the ugly. Um,
I don't know exactly what I'm
going to find at the outset. Um,
but basically you need to
put your confidence in me
that I'm going to be fair to
you, uh, that I'm going to
do my best to get it right.
We're always going to see eye to eye.
Um,
and it turned out that at the time he
had been thinking about writing his own
memoir and it was kind of
a, a difficult thing. Like,
he was just going to hire somebody to do
it and he didn't really have time. And,
and he sort of looked and thought, okay,
if you do this independent, um, uh,
number one,
more people are likely to read it
because it won't be sort of the world
according to Lee, a whitewashed version.
Um, and, and number two, I mean,
I think he had confidence in me that
I knew the science and could put it in
context.
So he agreed to let the chips fall.
I'll agree to all the interviews you
willing to do. I'll open up my papers.
So he was really good at,
uh, at being cooperative.
So often you hear, uh, about about, uh,
you know, biographies in that format.
And I think that was even the case with
Isaacson and jobs where there was kind
of a tension or a debate it in it, but
it sounds like he was overall, you know,
open to it and actually relieved.
I have to read the book himself.
Are there, there ones that I mean,
but certainly there were tensions,
um,
especially getting closer to the end when
you're fact checking some parts of the
story that don't jibe with his version of,
um,
and he'd give us a couple
of examples. Well, um,
so it might be hard for those
who haven't read the book,
but there's a passage in here in which
I report on how he was ousted as the
chairman of biology at Caltech and
that was not reported at the time.
So when hood left Caltech in 1991,
he was recruited by Bill Gates to the
University of Washington and this was sort
of like the dawn of a
technology driven biology,
biology becoming more data driven,
more of an information science.
He and gates shared this vision and
it was a big story when, you know,
this great scientists from
Caltech came to Seattle.
It was in the Wall Street Journal and
none of the underlying tensions of what
really led to his departure
from Caltech where reported.
Now as a biographer looking at these
things in the documentary record and
interviewing people 20 years later,
you can dig deeper and get
into more of the story. And,
and that was embarrassing and hurtful.
And there were times during the fact
checking process when Lee would try to
revert back to the, uh, the silica,
the cover story that Caltech was telling
that enabled him to save face at the
time. So we, we had some tensions.
We had some battles, right?
Are those things, one of the
things I took away as I was, uh,
as I was reading through the book is
that there's this element to Lee that I
think is similar to some of the
other great innovators of our time.
Whether you think of a Steve Jobs,
uh, you know, or an Eric Lander,
kind of the variety of other, um, folks
who we all kind of see, see in the media,
uh, or in our companies and whatnot. Um,
where there's a bigger than
life sort of quality. There's a,
this is the grand vision
of what we're going to do,
even though it may not be clear how
we're going to do it at the outset.
Um, as you spent time with Lee and wrote
the book and thought through that came
through in the book, that there's
clearly that part to his persona. Um,
did you find that that was balanced by
some other part where it's like, you know,
he also did produce the first
automated sequencer, right?
That's a technical achievement.
You know, how much of, you know,
to the extent that achieving great things,
uh,
takes breaking through barriers and
looking at the world in different ways in,
in somebody's likely, you know, what PR,
how much of him is grander than a
grand and how much of it is, look,
we've got to make the stuff work. Is
it 50, 50, or, you know, just as you,
as you dug into his persona,
how much of it did you see?
Or maybe there's a
different framing a to it,
especially as you've talked to some of
these other entrepreneurs who have, uh,
those parts to their
persona personas as well.
It's a great point.
There really are some common personality
traits that you see in the people that
really shake up a field and, and, uh,
lead us to a new,
a new path.
And it really is this
single minded intensity, uh,
that, so first is the vision. Um,
and he is a biologist first and foremost.
This is, this is where he came from,
that his training,
uh,
and he really wanted to answer big
questions about biology that you could not
answer.
Uh,
things like how is it that we are able
to moat an infinite number of antibodies
in our immune system to protect us from
all these pathogens in the environment,
the viruses, the bacteria,
when we only have,
we don't have a gene for every single
one of those. How does that happen? Uh,
they didn't have the tools for that,
so he,
he wanted the answer really
bad. And you know, he was, um,
dedicated to using,
to developing technology to,
to run bigger,
broader experiments to gather the
kinds of data that you would need to,
to answer a question of that
magnitude. And, um, he just,
once he developed the vision,
he just had this single minded intensity
and you can even see on the cover photo
of the book, that photo
captures it. Uh, it's,
it's like this guy is in the
zone. He's like, you know,
tiger woods lining up for a Putt, or,
you know, uh, Lance Armstrong on the,
you know, in the Tour de
France, uh, there's a focus,
a purpose, and, and no buddies rules,
nobody's bureaucracy. Nobody's, uh,
sensitivities are going to
get in the way of that goal.
That's who he who he was.
And so it was both his great
strength and at times a weakness.
Yeah. Yeah. Which I feel like we see so
much so often that those two things, um,
both change the world, but also can
be painful for the people around them.
That must've come out as you were talking
to the people surrounding we as well,
just kind of the inspiration
that they draw and, and
perhaps some of the challenges of,
uh,
of working in the environment
that's created in that.
That's right. Yeah. He, uh,
he threw off a tremendous amount
of energy. Uh, Roger Perlmutter,
who is now the president of Merck
research labs, had this great quote,
and he said that Lee is like of the son.
He throws off all of this is heat
and energy and he draws people.
He's got this great gravitational pull.
He draws people into his orbit. They do,
they're stimulated,
they do a lot of their best work,
graduate students and
postdocs. Um, but, um, uh,
it can be a little overpowering
at times as suffocating in some,
some cases
you invoked, um, uh, uh, the context
of Gordon Moore and, and, and,
uh,
and kind of Intel and kind of the amazing
work that was done to develop kind of
infrastructure, kind of these
fundamental tools or, or, um, uh,
you know, components that kind of
raised the whole field. And, and I,
I think that that analogy kind of runs
true, uh, uh, to the work hood. Did,
um, you know, kind of as, as you
kind of think through, um, the, uh,
the way that the various instruments
that could develop unlocked biology.
Do you feel like we're, we're, um,
we're seeing the full vision
of what Lee had had, um,
envisioned all the way back then today?
Or do you still feel like there's
a lot more, uh, to be unlocked?
Clearly we're seeing sequencing and
all that sort of stuff, but there,
are there other components of the vision
that you heard from him that we're
still waiting to see? Absolutely.
Yes. We're still in the early days.
And just for a little bit of historical
context, I mean, you know this,
you've read the book,
but it,
when hood was a really emerging on
the faculty at Caltech in the 70s,
uh, the first, uh,
manual DNA sequencing techniques were
being developed and these were slow,
tedious processes.
A graduate student would spend his or
her entire graduate school career and get
a phd based on determining
the sequence of just one gene.
So five years, you determine the sequence
for making something like insulin.
Right now,
today you can scrape off a skin
cell and sequence the entire genome,
the entire 3 billion bases
that are, are you in me? Um,
in seconds? Well the A, an
entire genome and say a day,
but like that gene would happen in
a split second. So, you know, the,
He v envisioned,
um,
automation coming to
biology at a time when, um,
the tools were very rudimentary in manual.
And furthermore,
there was a technophobic
attitude within biology.
There were people in biology
saw themselves as kind of
like high priests and we
don't really do this sort of thing
that we don't make widgets or tools.
That's the work of industry.
Um, and so hood, uh,
came in and said, no, we need to do both.
We need to develop better tools to
ask bigger and deeper questions.
We need to gather new kinds of data
and turn it into a bigger kind of
information science.
And he,
he saw not just DNA sequencing but,
uh,
other layers of information being
crucially important to like thoroughly
understanding the whole organism.
So, uh, he, he developed a,
what they call them micro chemical
facility at Caltech where they would, uh,
they sequence proteins.
They synthesize proteins,
sequence DNA and synthesize DNA for
instruments working in harmony that would,
um, read and write in the
language of life so to speak.
And by looking at the different layers
of information you could see, um,
you know,
how things go awry and become diseased
in a much more granular fashion than,
than you could before.
You know, certainly, uh,
sitting inside of Google kind of, uh, you
know, those four components. Uh, you know,
you see some of, some of which have have
totally transformed the industry. Uh,
you know, it feels like there's
still a, you know, more to come in.
It's certainly from a, from a
Google perspective, the role that,
the amount of data that's produced
from that set of instruments, uh,
you know,
is clearly profound and,
and would suggest that
there's other infrastructure,
other tool sets that need to be built
to manage it and help get to that
underlying ability or that,
that ultimate goal of a reading and
writing in the language of biology.
How much of that part of it have you seen?
We hood kind of focus on having
done all the instruments, you know,
thinking about, okay, oh, there's all this
data that's coming off the instruments.
You know, I, I think you referenced a
couple of things that he was doing, but,
but where, you know, where
did that research take you as,
as you're thinking through now that these
instruments kind of exist or parts of
them exist? You know, what's next?
Well, it's a great question because you
know, you can argue that we haven't yet,
uh,
reap the dividends of the human genome
project and genomics or information rich
biology whenever you'd like to call it.
Um,
because I think we're still
very much in the early days. Uh,
we're learning that biology is,
even as you peel back more
and more layers of the onion,
it gets more and more complicated.
So the gene sequence, as you know,
it's not absolutely deterministic.
Just because you have a
genetic abnormality doesn't
necessarily lead directly to
the path of disease. There are
other points at which, you know,
proteins, cells, you know,
you need to get a more full picture and
we're not there yet, uh, of uh, and,
and so there are efforts, um, in fact,
Google's baseline project as one to
try to, you know, better integrate,
um,
these multiple layers of information
from genes to protein cells,
but also your observable phenotype
that's in your electronic health records.
And we have some challenges
with electronic health
records in this country and
interoperability getting
different data sets to,
to line up and talk to
each other. So that's, um,
that's gonna take years to two words.
True. I remember in the book
you described a era of all, uh,
which was a company that
already has a company that, uh,
hood had chest I think got launched
maybe just as the book was, uh,
coming to press. Any news about
that? Anything that you've heard or,
or cause it seemed like that was starting
to get to some of these, uh, you know,
questions around phenotype and how to
tie all this stuff together with the
genetic underpinnings.
Yeah. So for those unfamiliar,
Arivale is accompany.
It started another startup company
that hood has gotten involved with, uh,
and it's trying to bring about
what he calls scientific wellness.
So this is a big data
approach to your health.
They start with, uh, people see having
their genome, their full genome sequenced,
uh, but, uh, once, cause that's all you
need, that's static set of information.
But then periodically say once
a quarter you'll get your money,
you'll give a blood sample
or spit, um, and uh,
that will be analyzed for the metabolites.
So what are the key metabolites that are
showing up in greater concentration or
another in your blood that
might be sending something awry?
A signal of disease perhaps? Uh,
they also sequence your microbiome.
We're learning a lot because of the
tool that enables us to sequence all the
microbes in say, a stool sample. You can,
you can get a sense of, uh, one's health,
a snapshot. It's constantly changing,
right?
Because the composition of your microbes
is influenced by your environment. Um,
so, um, by,
by gathering what he calls
a dense dynamic data cloud.
So starts with your
genome, the Metabolome, the
proteins, the proteome, uh,
the microbiome.
All of these ohmic levels of
information get combined and,
and hopefully by gathering all of this,
they can see,
say,
a sign of an early
warning sign of disease.
So do you have something that kind of
looks like it might be prediabetes heading
on the road toward, um, you know, a
more classic measurement of disease,
like your hemoglobin a, one
c being too high, you're,
you're unable to control your blood sugar.
Can we see,
can we see it by gathering
all of this information,
there's going to be a lot of noise.
Can we find that signal?
Can we apply computers to,
to identify disease at a point at
which we can intervene and potentially
correct, uh, before it's too late?
And so they, they've layered in a,
what they call a wellness coach. So
someone who works with, you know,
a computational biologist looks
at the data and says, you know,
I think there might be a signal here,
tells that to a coach who is not exactly,
you know,
sort of like a nurse practitioner
who says, you know, Krishna,
I'm seeing something kind of worrisome
with your blood sugar. You know,
you might want to lay off the ice
cream before bed. Um, and, and if so,
can we get, when we check a quarter
after, can we see like that, that,
uh,
that molecular perturbation
has disappeared and you
no longer look like you're
on the path to prediabetes.
Now this is really pretty exciting stuff,
but, um, it's not exactly being done.
It's not done in the traditional context
of randomized controlled trials that
are the way at which, you know, we,
we try to control for all the variables
that might be influencing our health.
So there's plenty of skeptics
out there who say, you know,
this is kind of interesting, but it's
not giving us definitive proof that, um,
that what you're doing is really working.
Right.
Um, I did want to get back
a little bit to the, uh,
the Seattle and kind of the various
sorts of geographies. You see. Um, I'll,
I'll turn to the audience in a little
bit and ask a couple questions. So, uh,
Qsen thoughts up here in a
moment, but, uh, but you know,
on your website you mentioned that you've
been through a two bosses and one and
a half booms I think in the,
in the biotech sector. Um,
and I would assume that we're kind
of still in the middle of a boom, uh,
from your perspective. So would maybe be
curious your perspective on, you know,
where we are in a cycle here, having
lived through a few yourself. Um,
but I'd also be really curious,
I mean, you mentioned, you
know, there was a world,
uh, when you started your career
where Microsoft and Boeing,
where the big industries in
Seattle, where are things today, uh,
in Seattle and then,
and then how are you seeing the various
geographies that you spend time in?
The big ones that I think of are of
course Seattle, the bay area, you know,
San Diego, New York, Boston.
Do you spend time in all of these
different geographies and what,
what are you seeing since you kind
of perhaps more than most have,
have a spectrum of,
uh, insight across, uh,
what various companies
are up to in academics?
Yeah. Yeah. So first question
about the boob. Um, yeah, I mean,
we reached a peak there
in the summer of 2015, um,
where there was, you know, kind of
a, a record number of FDA approvals.
There was a record amount of venture
funding. The stock markets were,
we're all riding high. Um, and uh,
then came Martin Shkreli and
some drug pricing controversies,
which scared some investors
thought maybe, uh, the,
the presidential election will go some
direction that might clamp down on drug
prices. So it, it fell
down for a while. Um,
now in the last this year,
things have rebounded to some extent
and we're now back on track again toward
pretty close to a record
number of FDA approvals.
There are some very exciting
drugs, which you know of. So I,
I'm pretty optimistic
that, uh, things are, uh,
exciting things are happening
with, with regularity. Um,
a lot of it here in the Boston area
now to, uh, to the geography question.
I mean, Seattle has been utterly changed
in the 16 years that I've been there.
The biggest one being the
emergence of Amazon. Um,
they now have about 40,000 employees in
the city of Seattle and they've plopped
them all just north of downtown. So
there's a tremendous amount of, you know,
bars and restaurants and you know,
condos and street activity that,
that wasn't there and kind of a
previously rundown part of town. Uh,
it's brought a lot of growth,
a lot of good economic growth,
but also some growing pains,
traffic and housing prices
as familiar story to many,
uh, tech clusters. Um,
but, um, as for biotech,
I mean, I, um,
I remain based in Seattle and there's a
terrific base of research there at the
Fred Hutchinson Cancer Research Center
and the University of Washington in a few
other nonprofits.
The Gates Foundation is there and
leading the charge on infectious disease.
Uh, but, um,
I get to Boston and San
Francisco and the most, uh,
because these are the
top two biotech clusters.
So I'm meeting with companies
and scientists and investors
in those two places
quite a bit. Um, San Diego as
well. New York once in a while.
Um, the, the way biotech has
grown as an industry, we, um,
it does tend to concentrate by geography
around great academic research centers.
Uh, great hospitals. Um,
and then the money in the entrepreneurs
and then all the service providers,
all of the consultants, the law
firms, the, everything that you need,
the regulatory affairs specialists,
everything that you need kind
of needs to be in, in one place.
So that's the way it has evolved.
Let me see if there's any
questions from the audience here,
wondering if you looked at any of the new,
uh,
diesel therapies that
are coming out of that.
Yes,
yes.
So, uh, for those unfamiliar on Novartis,
one FDA approval just a couple of
weeks ago for the first, uh, car t, uh,
immunotherapy, um, in this, uh,
this is a therapy in which patient
with cancer blood cancer, uh,
has white blood cells withdrawn.
They go off to a company lab,
they use some gene therapy to reprogram
the receptors to recognize a specific
marker on cancer cells. And
then they reinfused those, uh,
those t cells to go in and
kill the cancer. Um, and the,
they have seen extraordinary results
in small groups of patients with blood
cancers,
something like 80% complete remission
rates in kids with a acute lymphoblastic
leukemia. So, Eh, this is a very
exciting development. I mean,
we just don't see 80% complete
response rates, uh, in, you know,
serious cancers with traditional small
molecule or targeted antibody therapies.
So, uh, and furthermore, we're beginning,
we're starting to gather the longterm
followup data you need to say, yes,
this is actually lasting.
Uh,
so very exciting moment. Um, and uh,
there are lots of La,
there's been an incredible boom,
this is part of the story of the last
five years is that immunotherapy has
really come to the fore in cancer.
This is no longer like a
fringe science idea. Um, it's,
it's the main stage of cancer.
Every company that's in cancer,
every cancer center is focused on how
can we redirect that power of the immune
system to go after the cancer cells.
You actually have a feature on
your website Timmerman report.
If our call that was a review of
every company in the Immuno space done
alphabetically. If I
had gone, it was like,
it was pages and pages of companies and I
was like, this is amazing. Uh, you know,
how did you put that together? That
seemed like just an uh, you know,
superhuman level of effort to put
that amount of um, uh, data together.
And I was looking through it and thinking,
oh my gosh,
like it's just the only way to organize
this is, is alphabetically. It is.
Cause every, everyday there's
a new company in this space.
It really is hard to keep up with
all of the scientific approaches,
all the companies getting
money. Um, so yeah,
I found myself scratching my head and
saying, how can I get a handle on this?
So why don't I just go a toZ and try
to find as many companies as I could.
And there was something like 180 companies
and I just wrote short profiles of
each one of them back to back
along with some links to, you know,
primary sources where he might be able
to gather more specific information on
each and almost as many
immuno therapy companies.
Is there a video sharing companies?
I think.
Sure. Two quick ones.
One just about leave it.
I'm just curious that the
back in the day,
do you think any part
of that is the conflict?
What was rid of the
traditional, you know, science?
That's a
a great question. And
absolutely, yes. So Hud, um,
because of the scope of this
vision as it was really,
uh,
as he was bringing in the resources
and the people to make it happen,
his lab grew.
Uh,
he started colonizing more
and more space on campus. Uh,
he was the chairman and you know,
he saw like all of this as being part of
his grand quest didn't necessarily pay
a lot of attention to what the small
science, uh, people in the faculty,
um, what their priorities
were. Um, and so he,
he ended up,
it,
it evolves when you have 60 or 80 people
in a lab and the guy down the hall has
five or six graduate students working on
some very narrow, esoteric problem. Uh,
you know,
it's,
it challenged the whole culture of
the way caltech operated or really any
university for that matter.
The principal investigator led model with
five or six graduate students has been
irrelevant for a long time and it's
given us a lot of good science.
So people in the small science world
looked at this and thought, what is this?
I mean, how can you even adequately
supervise these people are, who are they?
Are they tenure track faculty or are they,
you know,
are they pro like employees
of like a little copany?
Do we actually have like a little company
now inside of Caltech? Um, it was,
it was strange people and,
and,
and it clashed with a lot of the identity
of the Cole Caltech really saw itself
as this elite institution
doing these rarefied yeah.
Things
after and after he was at Caltech,
you know,
we've talked before about journalism
been disrupted by various changes.
Do you see academia that he
says being disrupted? I mean,
obviously the Dapps it's pretty
smart people, but only to like, oh,
let's see. In terms of academic
straddling that line in biology between,
you know, the large invention type
laboratories or the source that you have,
you're in Cambridge versus
what was more classic
elite investigators.
I would say that these two forms
can now coexist more easily.
Um, so, uh, small science
is still alive and well.
Well, I mean, it has, it has, it's,
the model is still intact. I mean,
there are challenges to it.
Uh, with, uh, the NIH budget,
I'm constantly under pressure.
Um,
but big science has carved out
more of a place for itself.
Big Project driven that's a little more
industry like occurs at a place like the
brode. Uh, that's fortunate enough
to attract philanthropy, uh, that,
that can look a little further out at a
longterm goal than say your classic Aro
one NIH grant,
which is more on a three to five year
timeframe to show some results. Um,
you know, I mean, but there's a lot of
tension still between the two. I mean,
there's the whole data sharing
question. Um, you know,
a lot of principal investigators,
I mean, they make their, uh,
their name and their field by getting
published in science and nature and, and,
and not by,
you know,
dumping all their raw data out in public
databases for other scientists to,
you know,
gather and learn from in real time.
So we have a t a serious time
lag problem in academic science.
Now,
big science has still
has that cultural issue,
but I think to a lesser degree, I'd be
curious to hear your thoughts on that,
Krishna. But you, you know, you
see some cases of uh, you know,
bigger institutions,
I think they might be more inclined to
lead on this and say, you know, like, uh,
Daniel Macarthur over at the brode
institute, some of you may know he's a,
he's got this database for
exomes 60,000 or even more, uh,
uh,
collections of big datasets that from
each 60,000 individuals who have had scans
done on the 2% of their genome
that makes code for proteins.
That's pretty useful. And, um,
he is actually able to advance his career
by putting this out in the open and
then letting other people
share in that resource.
So I think we're beginning to see some,
some cultural changes between small
and big science, but you know,
change is hard. It
takes a long time. Yeah.
Is it a piggy back on that last question,
if you can look in your crystal ball
looking into the future and biotech
based on what you know about Seattle?
No. And you said the mindscape is
fundamentally change because of Amazon.
Do you think biotech could work?
Is moving to Seattle,
San Francisco, Boston,
Cambridge are definitely helps,
but we're becoming crowded,
very expensive.
Is there a room there?
Is there a willingness there to sort of
expand beyond Amazon into buying tech?
Or do you think it's
going to stay the Hans,
you're going to stay in San Francisco?
Cambridge,
I think a Boston and San Francisco are
a head and shoulders above the other
clusters and will likely remain that way,
um,
as the rest of our lifetimes.
Um,
there's so much historical,
uh,
momentum behind the basic research to
clinical care, the venture capital,
the history of entrepreneurship,
that human capital pool that's here.
I'm in a place like Seattle.
You have a few pieces of the puzzle,
but not all of them. Um, you have the
basic research that's world class.
Um, but, uh, you know,
I didn't mention this,
but when I started covering the
industry, uh, there was, uh,
a company called Immunex,
uh, which, uh, developed, uh,
the drug called Enbrel,
which was still to this day,
the 20 years later is one of the top
five bestselling drugs in the world.
It's really a major step forward
for rheumatoid arthritis.
Other drugs have come forward since
then, biologically enabled. And um,
the company wasn't able
to hold on to that.
It ended up getting acquired by Amgen.
A lot of the assets and
people moved elsewhere.
And so Seattle is like a lot of these
other hubs of biotech that doesn't,
it has some aspects of
what you need. But, uh,
in this case it doesn't have the,
the pool of sales and marketing people
or executive tailored that venture
capitalists typically what to
see before they see new things.
Um, and you have that in a
place like Boston, Cambridge.
Um, so, you know,
I'm sure Krisha has no shortage of people
that you can imagine running startup
companies here in Boston. Yeah, yeah.
We're surrounded by them. I, I'm curious,
I mean, if you were to zoom out a level,
um, and look at the biotech industry, uh,
over the time you've been
covering it, you know, ah,
there's the gigantic a Pharma
entities, uh, you know,
that we all know the Pfizers, the
Roche, the Mercks, uh, you know, um,
there's the small companies that
we finance and that, uh, you know,
aren't doing exciting, a new science.
Maybe some of them are public, usually,
you know, uh, call it, you
know, billion are under
sort of market caps.
And then we have kind of this
interesting array of companies, um,
like vertex cell gene. I mean
Gilliad I mean, these have become,
these are companies I think we've seen
go from kind of startups to kind of,
you know,
small midsize companies to like,
they're becoming pretty large companies.
And some of them have done deals that
are billion dollar acquisition is $1
billion deals and they can kind of do
it without breaking too much of a sweat.
Uh, you know, if you were
to dial the clock forward,
just given the context you've had
over all these years, you know,
what do you think happens
with those companies?
You think they get acquired
by the big entities? Do you
think that they, you know,
grow up a lot of them kind
of, um, and I'm sure you've,
you've been on the receiving end of all
of their pitches as they kind of to talk
to you about various announcements.
They all have kind of,
I think the framework of, look,
we're going to be the next mark.
We're going to be the next, uh, you know,
Genentech, Roche. Do you believe it?
Do you believe that those companies
are kind of grow into the next, uh,
big behemoths are, you know, what do you,
what do you think
happens with those folks?
You know, it's a great question. I
think maybe it's a minority of the time.
Maybe one fourth of the
time those visions are,
are realized by a company that gets
over the Hump and develops a new drug.
I mean,
just getting one drug over the finish
line as an FDA approved product.
And, and, you know,
really helping patients and
getting adequately reimbursed
and making good money.
I mean, very, very few companies
ever get through that funnel, um,
and even fewer can do it twice. So, um,
you know,
this is that the company down the
street Alnylam pharmaceuticals is a good
example. So they've got RNA interference,
gene silencing technology. They, they did,
they locked up a lot of IP early
on. They raised a lot of money, uh,
broadened smart people and 15 years
later they just now have the phase three
validating data necessary for
treating one rare disease.
Uh, which looks like that's going to be
a drug now they can start making money.
Um,
but that really is not enough for
them to become an enduring entity.
They need to do it at least one or two
more times to get diversified like a
Celgene or a Gilliad.
Even Gilly and Celgene have their
diversification challenges. You, you,
you look at how they make
their money and often it's,
it's one big thing you
that does it for the
even, I mean, just, I mean, just to call
it out. I mean, even for the cell genes,
the Gilliads, um, the vertexes,
I mean these are companies
that are actually pretty
big. Um, but to your point,
like they still ha they're
not fully diversified.
And I guess that's maybe that's one
of the questions like, uh, you know,
there's the,
there's the Alnylam is,
and can they make the leap into
becoming a commercial organization?
And that's something that, I mean,
obviously John's a phenomenal,
phenomenal leader, you know,
uh, you have adios, similar,
and I think you wrote an article
about this. Like, you know,
that shift in culture from being an
early stage r and d company to becoming a
commercial organization,
that's its
own challenge. Even after you have the
successful drug that's been approved,
can you kind of convert the company
and to a commercial organization?
When you look at these, this next level
of company is the Vertex is sell jeans.
Um, you'd Giliad's which
have like maybe a, you know,
a small number of assets that
are producing huge revenues,
do you think that they will be able
to get to that diversification?
You think there's just as much risk there?
Uh,
as you see on the early
stage side of it? Yes. Um,
I mean it's sort of like the old saying,
you know, getting to the mountain top is,
is hard, but staying there is even
harder. Right, right. Um, you know,
Regeneron pharmaceuticals is one good
example of a company that's now got,
I think six approved drugs and they're
laying the foundation for genomics based
drug discovery.
Like really trying to link some of
these layers of information that I was
talking about earlier to try to
create something sustainable,
something that can,
with some degree of predictability and
reliability roll off a new FDA approved
drug once every couple of years.
I mean,
I mean it's still monumentally difficult
and expensive and things are going to
fail for reasons that you can't fully
understand even after you spent years and
millions of dollars. Um, but, um, I,
you know, the companies that I think,
you know,
are able to invest in enough pieces of
the R and d puzzle are the ones likely to
endure. Um, you know,
I think in Alnylam and Regeneron and
these are companies that have a shot
because of the,
the investment in the basic science,
but often you see companies where that's
not even the intention at all. You know,
they just,
they take an asset out of Pfizer that
looks like it has some promise and it
needs some focus development for maybe
10 years. And that's all the goal is,
is to get that one drug approved,
sell it to a big Pharma Company,
ends up dollars, reward the shareholders,
and then the management who's exhausted.
We'll go sit on an island somewhere.
Let me see if there's any other questions.
I've got a couple of others lined up here,
but anybody else?
You were talking about
Seattle and Austin clusters.
What do you see around the rest
of the world as far as centers?
It's a good question. So,
um, the UK has some, um,
biotech infrastructure.
Germany is another, uh,
some in Japan,
but the vast majority of
new drug discovery and
development occurs in the u s
uh, there, uh, you know,
part of it I think comes back to the
decades of investment from the federal
government, the NIH in, in creating
centers of excellence. Um, but also,
um, you have an entrepreneurial
culture where, um, it's,
it's okay to gamble your career on one
of these projects and maybe fail and you
know, as long as she had, you know, don't
defraud somebody along the way. You know,
maybe you can try again. Um,
that's part of our culture.
We also have a stock market that is very
receptive and open to these very high
risk, high reward propositions. Um,
and that's not true in other
countries. Um, where, you know,
there's a little more reticence around,
you know, losing all of your money,
which does happen. Um, so, you know,
we could have a longer
conversation about this, but there,
there are special ingredients in the
United States that have enabled this to be
the place where a lot
of this activity occurs.
And now that's not
guaranteed to last forever.
I mean we're doing some
things that, that, you know,
like with immigration for instance, that,
uh, that could threaten our, our lead,
it could force some of this activity to
go elsewhere and it very well some of
the ingredients are in place
in other countries. They could,
they'd be happy to take it.
I know you're in town, uh, to, uh,
to do a bunch of things, but, uh,
but as a venture capitalist I'm
obligated to ask you about, um, the, uh,
the panel you're running later today
about how to avoid vcs and get the money
you need, but they actually
think it's a phenomenal topic.
I thought you were going to ask you
about your portfolio coach that's coming
next hour. We do that offline
that there've been, um,
but you know, I, you know,
there is kind of this interesting dynamic
developing where there are kind of a
new sources of capital coming into biotech
and maybe it's because we're in this
boom cycle of it. Um, but you know, I
think you've done that panel in other,
other settings or maybe what do you,
what are you seeing kind of out there,
aside from the traditional venture
approach to financing, uh, you know,
these risky, you know, crazy sort of
companies. Um, yeah. What, what, what,
what other sources of
capital or are there,
well,
I think you hit it on the head.
The reason for this is that
biotech has had a good road.
There were about three years in a
row where it outperformed the s,
the s and p 500 and the
Nasdaq composite index.
So anytime that happens you get more
money flowing in and saying, Gee,
I'd like to out perform the market too.
And so traditional VC
has been around forever.
And these are the folks who,
you know, they raised money
from pensions, endowments,
uh, limited partners,
corporations, corporations. Um,
and so they're out there raising
new funds every few years.
That's one form, the really the dominant
long lasting form of venture capital.
But there are all these other types out
there like corporate venture capital.
So GV is an example where you're not out
there raising money from endowments or
pensions. You've got some
money set aside. Generally.
I mean they come in different flavors,
but some money set aside from the parent
company that says we will, you know,
we will gamble some of this
money on biotech startups.
That's just part of our mission.
And some of them will pay off
in some won't just like any,
any venture capital firm. Um, but
we have our reasons for doing this.
Um, then there's also this emergence
of a disease related foundations. Yes.
So the,
these are nonprofit groups that in many
cases have an interest in a specific
disease area. Um, and
they fund basic research.
But I think in the last say
five to 10 years, a lot of
them have recognized, well,
that's not good enough. So
if you're, say the Michael J.
Fox Foundation for Parkinson's research,
um, you can invest in, you know,
the bright researcher down the
street at Dana Farber or you know,
Harvard medical school and that's great.
But their work is ultimately going to
lead to a published paper in the New
England Journal of Medicine.
And again, that's great,
but it doesn't go all the way
to a new Parkinson's treatment.
So how do you get there?
Well,
maybe you could take some of your money
and make equity investments in a spinoff
company that,
that takes that asset out of that lab.
And so many of them have
realized, can we, you know,
can we set up this sort of
equity investment component
within our, our charter,
the gates foundation does this for all
kinds of immunology related companies
that may have an application for
vaccines in the developing world that the
foundation cares about.
But it also may be useful for cancer.
And that would be like something that
traditional vcs and corporate vcs can,
can all get together on.
And you know, so, um,
you're seeing disease foundations,
corporate venture funds, uh, but also, uh,
now family offices. So this is sort of the
wealthy, the billionaire phenomenon. Uh,
something like a Peter Teal who, uh,
you know, it says, Gee, I'd like to,
I can start a company, a biotech company.
That's, you know, all I need is, you know,
a bright scientists and, uh, you
know, a team of advisers. Uh,
and what do you need, you know,
10, 20 million to, you know,
run the next set of experiments.
Um, go, go give it a shot.
So you got a lot of different kinds of,
of new investing entities. I haven't
got so many more questions for you.
Uh, but uh, but I'll, I'll
ask you them, uh, you know,
probably in another setting like
this. Um, well thank you Luke, for,
for taking the time to talk to us both
in the room and all the folks, uh,
virtually here. Um, you know, you,
you started things off by saying
that she kind of, you know,
you could've gotten to a variety of
different areas of journalism and you kind
of picked this area because of all the
exciting staff and people in it. Uh,
I think your book does a
phenomenal job of describing that.
So many books in this space, uh, are
kind of a slog to get through yours.
It was just a joy.
So hopefully everybody a out there and
in here gets a chance to experience that.
I thought the audio book was
phenomenal as well, but uh, uh,
but thank you for coming and hopefully
we get to do this more often as you write
more books. Thank you very
much. Pleasure to be here. Here.